this one is also very difficult because
you don't have a lot of space about here
is where you'll lose that space
to get to get around your apartment
so you have to stay you have to make a
hole keep it as i said the same thing
pull it through here through that hole
there
so
and um want you to study the techniques
not the not the whole part about
throwing
here what i'd like you to do is watch
my body and don't look at the foot and
think
you know you look at the foot you see
this and people think that you're
entering
this is key on this is what you should
be learning in the lower grades
what i'm doing is i'm actually
stimulating it by
showing you the move but this block
torso isn't going anywhere i then
this thumb's gonna actually fall to me
but it'll look like it's falling there
it's actually going to fall to me
i'll get out when it falls to me it
stays within that five centimeters
if it's all worked out all right
the hips pulls it through and you've got
your remember
if you did i thought you should be had
enough coat of ice for now
the only trouble with that is
if you think you're going to do a kind
of gosh
the person's got a good grip you end up
like that
once you've built up this thing you were
saying about you feel it in the
higher teachers once you've built up
that
coke
correct over the years
over the years
technical parts